اهلا بكم مشاهدينا في هذه المقابله الخاصه
التي نجريها مع رئيس البرلمان اللي بيبيع
جيلا صالح وذلك بعد قرار البرلمان ايقاف
رئيس الحكومه المكلف فتحي باشاغه كذلك بعد
تصريحات لافته من قبل المبعوث الاممي الى
ليبيا عبد الله في مقابله خاصه كذلك مع
ناوله التي قال فيها ان مجلسين والدولان
انتهت ولايتهما اذا ينضم الينا الان
اجل صالح رئيس البرلمان الليبي سياده
المستشار اهلا بيك وشكرا على قبولك الحديث
معنا
اهلا بك وقناتكم الموقره والساده
المشاهدين اهلا بك
سياده المستشار اعضاء البرلمان اللي
بيجتمعوا منذ ايام وقرروا ايقاف رئيس
الحكومه المكلفه
ولبدايه ان نفهم هذا القرار ما الذي يعنيه
لماذا ايقاف فتحي باشاغه حج بالثقه عن
حكومته
من المعروف ان مجلس النواب هو سلطه
التشريعيه التي ينتخب الشعب
وظيفه مجلس النواب
هو الرقابه على السلطه التنفيذيه
وسنه تشريعات
ففي مجلس النواب تشرع القوانين
وتحاسب السلطه التنفيذيه
صحيح ان
مجلس النواب من حق ان يساعد الحكومه
وايضا يشكل لجان التحقيق
وايضا يستجيب الحكومه لكن هذه الاجراءات
كلها تتطلب يعني اتخاذ اجراءات معينه النص
عليها عليها القانون
بالتاكيد يجب ان تكون التحقيق بعد سؤال
الحكومه في جلسه في مجلس النواب عندما يرى
مجلس النواب ان الحكومه يجب مساعدته
استدعى الحكومه للمساهله اذا اقتنع مجلس
النواب تاع الامر واذا راى ان هناك
توضيح بعض النقاط ان يشكل له ان يشكل لجنه
تحقيق
تقوم بالاتصال بالحكومه وطلب كل المستندات
اللازمه ثم تقدم تقريرها الى مجلس النواب
مجلس النواب قد يقتنع يعني بهذا
بما جاء في توصيات المجلس ان الحكومه ادت
واجبها كما كما يجب او ان هناك قصور تقصير
وعندها قد اذا كانت تقصير قد يكون يعني
هناك نقص في التشريع
فيغسل المجلس من سد هذا النقص في التسريع
او توجيه الحكومه الى الى عمل معين اما
اذا تبين ان هناك مخالفات
تستجوب استجواب الحكومه يجب ان يقدم طلب
من عدد من النواب الى رئاسه مجلس النواب
تذكر فيه النقاط المطلوب استجواب الحكومه
فيها يبعث هذا
الاجرائي الى رئاسه الحكومه
لترد على هذه الاستفسارات يستطيع مجلس
النواب اذا اقتنع
باجابتها كان بها وان لم يقتنع فله ان
يسحب الثقه منها ولكن هذا الاجراء الخطير
يتطلب اتخاذ اجراءات قانونيه معينه يجب
التقيد بها
تحقيقا للمصلحه العامه
كذلك هذا الاجراء سحب الثقه الاجراء خطير
ومهم جدا يجب ان نتاكد ان الاجراءات صحيحه
وان الحكومه تستحق ان تستجب في هذا الامر
نعم
ولكن لماذا يصف البعض مع الجاره في الجلسه
السابقه بالامر غير المفهوم حتى رئيس مجلس
الدوله كان وصف ايقاف شغا بالاجراء المريب
وانتم
سيد عقيله صالحه لم تكونوا في جلسه ايقاف
فتح بشاره
وهذا الكلام صحيح يعني هذه الاجراءات يجب
ان تتخذ طبقا للقانون للاسف الشديده هناك
تصرف فعلا في هذا الاجراء ولكن ان كان
هناك خطف الخطر لا يعالج بالخطا يجب
المجلس النواب ان يتدرس هذا الامر من جديد
الامور في نصابها الصحيح صحيح صحيح ان
الاتفاق السياسي يقول انه يجب ان يكون
هناك اتفاق بين مجلس الامه ومجلس الدوله
التسجيل الحكومه ايضا عندما يتقرب سحب
الثقه يجب ان يكون هناك تشاور هذا الامر
حقيقه هناك حصل في التسرع ولكن كما قلت
يعني هذه الامور تعالج من قبوه البرلمان
البرلمان هو سيد نصر لكن يجب ان يلتزم
بالقوانين كما هي مقرره وخاصه القانون رقم
اربعه لسنه 2014 بالنظام الداخلي لمجلس
النواب اذا طالما لم يلتزم بالقانون لم
يشرك مجلس الدوله ولم يقم بالاجراءات
بطريقه صحيحه قبل ايقاف فتح بشاعه
حقيقه
حقيقه هناك تصرف في هذه العمليه كان يجب
ان تاخذ كما يقرره القانون يجب ان تستدعى
الحكومه للسؤال للاستماع اليها ثم تشكل
لجنه التحقيق لا يجوز وقف الانسان قبل ما
تسمح يعني
لما تريد سواء في الجانب الجنائي وفي
الاداري تريد ان توقف شخص يجب ان تستمع
الى اقواله تحقيقا للعداله ولحقوق الانسان
وحتى يستطيع كل كائن يدافع عن النفس
انا حقيقه تكلمت حتى مع النائبين ومعظم
الذنوبنا نحن يجب علينا تصرح في هذه
الهجره ويجب ان نستطيع الحكومه
للاستماع اليها نعطيها الفرصه معينه بعد
اسبوع 10 ايام ويوجه اليها ما هو مطلوب من
الرد عليه حتى تتخذ الاجراءات حقيقه شاهدت
ان هناك
تسرع اسرار على اتخاذ هذا الاجراء انا لا
يمكنني ان نقف ضد اراده المجلس النواب
لكنني نستطيع ان نقول رايي ونقف معه فكنت
فعلا غير راضي على الطريقه وليس على حمايه
للشخص او ان المجلس النواب مهوش محق في
بعض
الاتهام الحكومه بالتقصير او القصور ولكن
الرجل باعتبار الرجل القانون ملتزم بتنفيذ
القانون خاصه على رئيس السلطه التشريعيه
التي تصدر القوانين وتحاسب الحكومه على
مخالفه القرن فكيف يكون لمجلس النواب ان
لا يراعي هذه القوانين اذا مجلس النواب
اليوم مطالب باجراء اخر لتصحيح المسار
الذي ترفضه انتهى الامر عليكم ان تتعاملوا
مع مساله ايقاف فتحي باشا
ليس العيب ان الانسان ان يقضي ولكن العيب
ان يتبادل في الخطا في امكان المجلس
وبضربه بعض الامور ان يقوم بالتصفيه
واعتقد ان هذا الاتجاه الان لان غالبيه
كيف
يصحح الخطا سياده المستشار الان
وما وصفتها بالخطر لا في جلسات المجلس
يستطيع ان يعدل قرارات ان يستوفيل
الاستحقاقات المطلوبه في اي جلسه النواب
يرى بعض الاجراءات التي يجب
موحده ضمن صفقه سياسيه
هل فعلا هذا التوصيف سليم لما يرجى الان
في ليبيا
نريد ان نذهب للانتخابات وكنا جاهزين
للانتخابات شيء طبيعي ان تكون حكومه جديده
وحكومه واحده لا تنتمي لجهه الجهه ولا
يعني هناك شكوك في ادائه لواجبات وبالتالي
اذا كنا نريد الانتخابات يجب ان تكون
الحكومه حكومه محايده مهمه هو اداء
الانتخابات يعني لا يوجد شك في نزهتها او
في اداره العمليه الانتخابيه الوقت مناسب
لتشكيل الحكومات الوحده المكلفه
بقياده مرحله ما قبل الانتخابات والاشراف
على الانتخابات
اعتقد ان لا يوجد لا يوجد ما يمنع من
تشكيل الحكومه والاجراء في العمل العمليه
الانتخابيه متى ستجرى الانتخابات وفقا
اعتقادكم وفق نظركم لطريقه السير اتفاقات
نحن بالتاكيد
كما تعلمون شكلنا سته زائد سته القوانين
كمان معروف صادره من مجلس النواب سابقا
قانون انتخاب البرلمان القانون بالتاكيد
هو القانون حتى يعدل او يلغى سته زائد سته
بامكانها ان تعتمد القوانين ان تقوم
بتعديل فيها مجلس النواب ملزم بعد الاتفاق
يصادق على هذه القوانين بعد ان تصدر هذه
القوانين يجب ان تشكل حكومه كما قلت
الحكومه واحده العمليه الانتخابيه تعطى
بده محدده اجل محدده لاجراء الانتخابات في
المواد الذي يحدد
المغرب لاستكمال اجتماعاتها
الى اين وصلتم هل يمكن الحديث عن بدايه
صياغه البنود المتفق عليها
ما هو الخلافه يعني في نقاط كما قلت يعني
بالنسبه من جانبنا القوانين الصادره اذا
اخواننا في مجلس الدوله راونا تعديل على
بعض المواد اثنين ثلاثه اربعه مواد خمسه
يعني يجب الاتفاق على على احتمال قانون
حتى تتم على اساس الانتخابات الرياضيه
والبرلمانيه
من التواصل
لا هي نقاط الخلافيه اعتقد هي قضيه
الجنسيه الزواج الجنسيه
انا اقترحت عليهم حقيقه في زواج جنسيه
نحن لا يجوز ان نحرب كل ليبيا من ان يكون
لديه جنسية اجنبيه نحن لا نريد الرئيس او
النائب لديه جنسيه اجنبيه ولا يكون رئيس
او نائب الا بعد انتخابه قلنا انه يعطى
فرصه جميله للترشح عندما يفوز بالانتخابات
يتنازل عن جنسيته في الجيول يحدد وان لم
يتنازل يكون الرقم اثنين التالي هو رئيس
الدوله
اعتقد ان الامر سهل يعني
هناك قبول حتى الان من جميع الاطراف وهذا
يخرجنا من هذه العزبه الخلافات وابعاد
فلان وعلاء نحن لا نريد ان نستبعد احد ولا
نهم شاهد القاضي كما قلت والحكم هو صندوق
الانتقام لا تريدون استبعاد او استثناء اي
احد من الترشح للانتخابات هو نفس موقف
عبدالله المبعوث الاممي الى ليبيا في حديث
سابق منذ ايام معنا
هل هذا يعني بين ثمه اتفاق ليبي امامي
الان لسه محرج جميع للترشح بما فيهم
العسكريين وجوه النظام السابق وغيرهم من
الشخصيات الجبليه في ليبيا
اتجاهنا ايضا اعتقد انه سنلتزم بما تقرر
اللجنه القانون هو اللي يحكم يعني ما تتفق
عليه
وفي مجلس الدوله وايضا يكون هو اساس
الانتخابات
سيف الاسلام القذافي
لا لا نحن نحن لا نحترض على على ترشحات
كما قلت وانا مصر
او يقرب هو صندوق الاقتراب لا ما يصح لاي
شخص اشخاص شعب الليبي هو من يقول من يحكم
عن طريق صناديق الاقتراح اما بالنسبه نحن
لا نرفض ترشح لكن هل يقبل ان نترشح وهو
رئيس الدوله
الامنيه والكتابيه والاداريه اعتقد انا
تختل العداله ولم نكن هناك هناك مساواه
ما القاعده التي على اساسها سيمنع شخص من
الترشح لرئاسه ليبيا
هي القائد
ولكن على الاقل مقاربه ورؤيه
هي المقربه
واصحاب الجنسيه
وبعد يكون رئيس لا نتولى منصبه الدستوريه
في خلال مده محدده
والا يكون التالي له ومن يحل محله
بعدين تكمل
اليها هي الايصال الوصول الى الاطار
القانوني لهذه الانتخابات وقوانين
الانتخابات
تتحدثون عن تشكيل حكومه موحده
كيف ستتشكل ماذا عن حكومه دبيبه اذا
ما هو لما يصير لما يصير القانون نحن
نحتاج فعلا الى الانتخاباتنا ان تكون قبل
نهايه السنه
اذا نريد حكومه شغاله الانتخابات سيكون
هناك اتفاق بين مجلس الدوله ومجلس
وتشكيل الحكومه ورد في الاتفاق السياسي لا
عندما يتفق مجلس النواب ومجلس الدوله على
شكل الحكومه يجب ان تكون هي الحكومه
الشرعيه
تذكر معنا سياده المستشار بانه في
الانتخابات السابقه لم تجرى بسبب ما سمعت
المفوضيه الانتخابات حينها بالقوه القاهره
التي منعت اجراء هذه الانتخابات اذا
تحتاجون او هكذا يعتقد بينكم تحتاجون لجهه
ما
لتضمن سير هذه العمليه الانتخابيه من هي
هذه الجهه الدوليه او المحليه التي تشرف
تراقب هذه الانتخابات
اولا نلتقي مع السيد رئيس المفوضيه
الدكتور عماد السايح وقال لي انه على
استعداد اجراء الانتخابات لكن الخلاف انه
لا يمكن اجراء انتخابات الظليل الحكومتين
الحكومه في الشرق والغرب عندما تتوحد تكون
الحكومه واحده وهو جاهز للانتخابات كما
قال لي كما وايضا نطالب باشراف الدولي
وقف على الانتخابات لكن انا اعتقد ان قاره
اللجنه القوانين
ستتم الانتخابات ان شاء الله
مره اخرى دوليه
لتساعد ليبيا على الاشراف او على رقابه
وحتى على الضمان قبول كل الاطراف لنتيجه
الانتخابات
مساء الخير واضح بالنسبه لي هذا السؤال
لن تحتاجها دوليه لتساهم مع ليبيا في
مساله الرقابه على الانتخابات
والاشراف عليها وفي الاخير لتضمن كذلك
قبول جميع الاطراف الليبيه الان لنتيجه
الانتخابات لاحقا
لان نحن نرحب
الدول العربيه وكل المنظمات الالمانيه
يقبل بها كل الليبيين
وتخرج اراده الشعب الليبي في من يحكمه
ان يتحدث معك بصراحه وانقل وجهه نظر هي
متداوله الان في ليبيا البعض يعتقد بين
الجميع الان يسعى لتشكيل حكومه موحده
يقولون انها للاشراف على الانتخابات ولكن
في الحقيقه بحسب هذه الاطراف
ليس للاشراف على الانتخابات وانما لابقاء
الوضع على ما هو عليه
وهنا تشكيك برغبتكم ورغبه كل الجهات
الليبيه على اجراء هذه الانتخابات فعلا
الجميع يريد الانتخابات والدليل كنت امس
التقيت عدد كبير من من اخوتنا في الشرق في
الغرب الليبي كل الليبي يقترب انتخابات
والدليل هو تسجيل ما يقرب ثلاثه مليون
ليبيين يريدون الانتخابات ولكن
لا يوجد في تصوري الان ما يمنع لعمليه
الانتخابيه الانتخابيه الان عندما تنتهي
واتمنى ان تنتهي من مهامه قبل نهايه شهر
خمسه اللجنه سته زائد سته عندما تنهي هذه
اللجنه مهامه لا يوجد لاي انسان مبرر بان
يعرقل عمليه الانتخابات
لكن المطالبين بما
رئيس مجلس النواب ان الحكومه الانتخابات
يجب لا تكون حكومه تدبيبه ولا حكومه سيد
الحكومه لهذا الغرض تحدد مدتها بعدد قليل
بعدد قليل ومهم محدده
لديكم رؤيه واضحه حول شكل هذه الحكومه حول
من سيقود هذه الحكومه
نعم هل لديكم رؤيه واضحه حول شكل هذه
الحكومه من سيقود هذه الحكومه ترشحون
شخصيه لقياده هذه الحكومه الحكومه الوحده
نحن نحن كما قلت بعد تنتهي لجنه
سنلتقي مع الساده اعضاء مجلس الدوله
وستتفق على تشكيل حكومه مصغره ستكون
مهامها بالدرجه الاولى
انهاء الانتخابيه
لا يشكك احد في نوايانا فيما يتعلق بتشكيل
الحكومه حكومه وحده وطنيه
الجميع يرتاح له الانتخاب لا يوجد مبرر
خليفه حفتر ايا كان يترشح للانتخابات
وتوفر فيه الشروط يترشح وعلينا جميعا ان
نقبل نتيجه الانتخابات
كما تظهر بانتخابات نازيهه والشفافه
وتعتصراف الدولي كما ذكرت
الامم يقال ان مجلسين نواب والدولان انتهت
ولايتهما ودائما هناك حديث وموضوع جدلي في
ليبيا حول شرعيه مجلس النواب ومجلس الدوله
كيف تردون
لا هو اولا السيد باسيلي الى من يعطي
الشرعيه للمجلس النواب ولمجلس الدوله لكن
اعتقد ان التعبير يعني خانه التعبير يعني
يريد ان يقول ان هذه الاجسام تحتاج الى
تجديد الشرعيه لكن فيما يتعلق بالولايه
الولايه يقررها الدستور الدستور الليبي
يقول لان الدستوري يقول مجلس النواب هو
سلطه التشريعيه حتى يتم انتخاب مجلس نواف
جديد التي فقط سياسي يقول ان مجلس النواب
وسلطه التشريعيه الوحيده في ليبيا طيله
الفتره الانتقاليه فمن اين انتهت المده لا
توجد مده محدده مجلس النواب وابن ايضا من
مصلحه الوطن ان يستمر في مهامي منتخب مجلس
نواب جديد واتمنى ان يكون الانتخاب في
اقرب وقت ممكن
ان تاتي الولايه تعبير غير دقيق ربما يقصد
يعني يحتاج الى تسديد الشرعي وفعلا نحن
نطالب بانتخابات حتى تاتي اجسام جديده
وجود جديده
يحتاج للتعاون معكم مطالبكم
اظهار من اجل اجراء هذه الانتخابات
الى اي درجه انتم الان في تعاون اتصال مع
الحكم بالظاهر والله يتولى الصرائر نحن ما
نعلن عليه انا نريد الانتخابات ومخلصين
فعلا لاجراء الانتخابات لكن تقديرات اخرى
ويمكنهم ويمكن كذا نحن صراحه نريد
الانتخابات ونريدها في اول وقت ولكن طبقا
للقوانين وتحت اشراف الدولي وحكومه
مهمه محدده للانتخابات فقط ولا تطلع لها
لترشح لرئاسه الدوله مره اخرى
الانتخابات ربما يجب الحديث كذلك عن ملف
المرتزق الاجانب هناك لجنه معنيه بهذا
الملف ولكن انتم كالجسم ليبيا موجوده الان
معنيون ايضا
ما مقاربه مجلس النواب حول اخراج المرتزقه
من ليبيا
مجلس النواب بكل صراحه رئيسا لا نريد اي
قوات اجنبيه في ليبيا ولكن يجب ان تعمل
عمليه عن طريق المجتمع الدولي تخرج هذه
القوات بطريقه منظمه وجميعه وفي وقت يحدد
لكن
مجموعه من القوات تخرج مجموعه كذا ولكن
نحن لا نريد احد في بلادنا لا قواعد
عسكريه ولا قوات عسكريه اجنبيه نعم
بالعوده للحديث عن البرلمان اللي وعن ما
جرى في جلسه ايقاف فتحي باشا ومواصفها
مجلس الدوله بالاجراء المريب من قبله ولكن
هل صاحب ان ثم تاجواء متوتره اليوم بحسب
مصادرنا تقولون متوتره داخل البرلمان هناك
جبهه معارضه كبيره لكم
وكنتيجه منطقيه للاجواء المتوتره نرى هذه
القرارات غير المتفق عليها
يعني لا احكم الا بدليل لكن اللي واضح كما
قلت يعني في الاجراءات لم تتخذ الاجراءات
القانونيه الصحيحه وهذا الامر يقعد في
الخطا ولكن العيب هو الاستمرار في الخطا
بسلطه التشريعيه الوحيده في ليبيا بامكان
المجلس النواب يراجع قراراته او يسرع
بعمليه التحقيق كما قرر للوصول الى نتائج
واين يجب على ان يحدد حتى مده اداء اللجنه
لمهم لجنه التحقيق وبعد هذا الاجراء يجب
ان يتخذ الاجراءات الصحيح ان راى صعبه ثقه
من الحكومه علينا اتخذ الاجراء القانوني
حسب قانون المجلس ومن راى توجيه الحكومه
او سد اي نقص هو في التشريع وفي عمل
الاداره فهذا واجب مجلس النواب
يعني بعد التحقيق هذا يمكن ان يعود بفتح
البشر لرئاسه الحكومه
شيء طبيعي والا نكون حكمنا مسبقا قبل
التحقيق يعني بعد التقرير لجنه لجنه
التحقيق ربما
يوضح للمجلس
او الموضوع لا يستحق سحب الطريقه من
الحكومه توجيهه وتعديل او اي شيء اخر لكن
الحكم قبل
التقرير ومناقشه مجلس النواب لتقرير
اللجنه راح يكون حكم مسابقه
قصدي يعني التحقيق
يقولون الحقيقه بنت التحقيق يعني بعد
التحقيق سيطره لمجلس النواب
سيد باشاغه يثبت ان لا شيء عليه ويستمر
الحكومته ويقرر سحب الثقه للاجراءات
الصحيحه
بعض
التقارير التي تتحدث عن
بعض الخلافات ربما تحالفات جديده في شرق
ليبيا اليوم داخل البلمان وحتى في
الشخصيات التي في شرق ليبيا مع علاقتكم
اليوم مع كل الاطراف الليبيه واقصد الان
تحديدا خليفه حفتر
في حركتي جيده مع الجميع من المعروف ان
ليس لدي اعداء قد يكون لدي خسوف في وجهات
النظره السياسيه لكن نتعامل مع جميع
ونتعاطى مع الجميع
ولكن حل قضيه ليبيا كما قلت هي الانتخابات
عليها الجميع في الداخل والخارج من يريد
مصلحه ليبيا الامر بسيط جدا وهي حكومه
واحده تشتغل على الانتخابات والقوانين
اعتقد ان من الناحيه التشريعيه القوانين
الجاهزه احتاجت تعديل وان لم تعتاد
التعديل المفوضيه كما قال السيد
رئيس البخوضيه انه جاهز يريد سلطه واحده
فقط وهو محق في ذلك ايضا اذا كان هناك
تزوير كما يقال الان السيد النائب العام
قائم بواجب على اكمل وجه هذا الامر لا
يستغرق الوقت وتلغى
الارقام المزوره وتنتهي العمليه الانتخاب
ان شاء الله
هل تنوون الترشح للرئاسه
تسمع نسيت المستشار
امتنون دعم شخصيه اخرى ربما
حقيقه قبل قبل
تنتهي هذه العمليه لم اقرر يعني
بعد بعد الاتجاه الانتخابات وتستقر البلاد
ونتجه فعلا الانتخابات وتحدد الانتخابات
وتفتح ابواب التراس هيحدد موقف من هذا
الامر
شكرا جزيلا لك شكرا على قبولك الحديث معنا
مره اخرى رئيس البرلمان اللي بيعقل لصالح
شعبان
شكرا مشاهدينا كذلك على متابعه لهذه
المقابله خاصه ماريس مجلس النواب الليبياك
لصالح شكرا
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات